-Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it.
Guys,
some big entertainment news.
Netflix has officially confirmed
that a second season
of "Squid Game" is coming soon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, if you forgot what happened
in season one,
congrats --
that means therapy's working.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, after COVID, Ukraine,
and inflation,
critics are already calling it
"the feel-good comedy
of the year."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, this season's
gonna be pretty intense,
mostly 'cause all the players
are competing
for a single gallon of gas.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's talking about this.
A senior software engineer
at Google was suspended
after he claimed
that the company's
artificial intelligence
has gotten so powerful,
it now functions like a person
with thoughts and feelings.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah, the engineer knew
the robot was a real person
when it forgot this weekend
is Father's Day.
[ Laughter ]
"Google last-minute
Father's Day gifts."
"You're a real boy!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Google grilling."
That's right.
The Google employee claims
the artificial intelligence
acts like a 7- or 8-year-old.
Even more frightening,
here's what it looks like.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Well, some news from Washington.
Today, Congress held the second
January 6th Committee hearing.
Yep.
You know things are weird times
when the song of the summer
is the ABC News theme.
[ "ABC News" theme plays ]
[ Laughter ]
Uh, well, this morning on ABC,
they showed loud,
chaotic riot footage.
And then, after that episode
of "The View" was over,
they showed the hearing.
And --
[ Laughter ]
You guys
are a good crowd tonight.
I like this crowd.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys get it
Stay with us all week!
I want this energy all week.
I love this crowd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fantastic.
That's right.
So, today, every major network
covered the hearing,
even Fox News.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
They were like, "Might as well.
All our anchors
are in it anyway."
So, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Today's big witness
was supposed to be
Trump's former campaign manager,
Bill Stepien,
but he cancelled
at the last minute
because his wife
went into labor.
When the baby was born,
the doctor was like,
"It's a...lucky break,
is what it is."
[ Laughter ]
You know last night,
he was like,
"Honey, I made you a spicy
jalapeño casserole.
Eat up.
Let's take the stairs.
Let's take the stairs."
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
For the first hearing,
on Thursday,
over 20 million people tuned in,
which is higher
than this year's NBA finals.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Trump was torn.
He didn't know whether
to worry about the hearing
or brag about the ratings.
[ Laughter ]
"Biggest riot ratings
in history.
Just --"
[ Laughter ]
"Biggest.
People love the riot."
[ Laughter and applause ]
No, people don't love the --
Hey, I read that there's
a growing number of high-ranking
Democratic officials
who do not want President Biden
to run for re-election.
Biden believes that
he can get back on track
by crafting a tight,
concise message.
And then he talked
for three hours
about how he plans to do that.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Clicks tongue ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
Foul ball.
-Apparently, some Democrats
are worried about his age.
Yeah. Bernie Sanders
is like, "I agree.
He's too young!"
[ Laughter ]
"He's too young,
these whippersnappers..."
[ Laughter ]
"...wearing sneakers and..."
I saw that, due to a worldwide
shortage of helium --
this is true -- helium --
the National Weather Service
hasn't been able to launch
all their weather balloons.
It's tough. And I think
I have a pretty good idea
of what the meetings inside
the National Weather Service
are like right now.
[ Laughter ]
-[ High-pitched voice ]
Dale, why don't we have
any weather balloons in the sky?
-[ High-pitched voice ]
Well, Doug,
we don't have enough helium.
And without it,
it's hard to get up real high.
-I guess this is what happens
when there's inflation.
-It's a real kick
in the weather balloons.
[ Laughter ]
-Time to cut back on helium.
[ Valve squeaks,
helium hissing stops ]
-[ Deep voice ]
What a sad day.
I know, Doug.
-Also, today's my birthday.
-Oh! Sorry.
I almost forgot.
Happy birthday.
-Thanks!
-Doug, wait!
[ Explosion ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
[ Laughing ]
-Yeah.
-Wait. What?
-That happened?
-Yeah.
-They both had blonde hair.
-Yeah, that's what I imagine
is happening.
At the he-- at the National --
-And then helium
became a flammable substance.
That's great.
That's beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-Bill Nye over there.
-And that guy had
a really deep voice naturally.
-Yeah.
They both did, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news, everybody.
Coca-Cola --
I'm kind of excited about this.
Coca-Cola is teaming up
with Jack Daniel's
to release a Jack and Coke
cocktail in a can.
[ Audience "Oohs," applauds ]
There it is.
Look at that.
-Yeah.
-Finally, we no longer
have to go through that
exhausting task of mixing
Jack with Coke.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Right now, there are
four cases of this stuff
holding up a rusted truck
in Kid Rock's front yard.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this. Yesterday,
15 McDonald's restaurants
in Russia reopened
with new branding
along with a new name,
called Vkusno & Tochka,
which translates to
"Tasty and That's It."
[ Laughter ]
"Tasty and that's it."
-No more.
-Yep, they're really trying
to distance themselves
from the existing
McDonald's brand.
Check out this ad --
this latest ad I saw.
-[ Russian accent ]
If you're a fan of McDonald's,
then you'll love, or at least
tolerate, Vkusno & Tochka.
We offer all of menu favorite,
including fraction-of-kilogram
burger with dairy square,
room-temperature
potato shavings,
deep-fried poultry blocks,
the crispy traitor --
we mean chicken sandwich,
and milk sludge.
And if you see missing clown,
Donald McRonald,
please report to authorities.
Vkusno & Tochka.
♪ Ba-da, ba-ba-ba ♪
You will loving it.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-"You will loving it."
To distance themselves.
Hey, did you guys
hear about this?
Marvel has announced that
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
is going to return to theaters
with new and extended scenes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do people really
care about that?
[ Audience shouting "Yeah" ]
-Really? I thought it was like,
"See it again
but now with the scenes
that weren't good enough
for the real movie."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Spider-Man,
over at Disneyland,
they have a Spider-Man show,
right?
And there's a dummy
that's supposed to do
flips in the air and land on top
of a building
like it's Spider-Man,
but something went wrong.
And someone got video of it.
Watch this.
-Here goes something.
♪♪
-There he goes.
You're the man, Spidey.
Good luck, Spidey.
Good luck -- ooh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Wah-wah! ]
Ooh!
[ Laughter continues ]
Looks like Spider-Man after
a six pack of Jack and Coke.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, buddy!"
That's actually
in the extended scene
from the new "Spider-Man" movie
in theaters and IMAX.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And IMAX, of course.
Guys, some entertainment news.
A lot of fans are theorizing
that Beyoncé
has a new album coming soon
because of mysterious clues
that she dropped online
this weekend.
-Yeah, but how do you know
for sure?
Isn't that just a rumor?
-I mean, the clues
are everywhere, Tariq.
-Like what?
-Okay.
So, on Friday, Beyoncé
deleted her profile pictures
for all her social-media
accounts --
Twitter, Instagram, TikTok,
all of them.
And she still hasn't uploaded
new ones over 72 hours later.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Go on.
-Beyoncé's most recent studio
album was "Lemonade,"
which was surprise released
over six years ago in 2016.
But you know
what else happened in 2016?
Her second Super Bowl
performance,
the one with Coldplay.
And we all know what happened
the day before that performance.
She surprise released the song
for the video "Formation."
Then immediately after
the Super Bowl, the next day,
she announced The Formation
World Tour all before
anyone even knew that she was
going to surprise release
"Lemonade" that April!
-Well, that was 2016, though.
-Right, right, right,
but both "Lemonade"
and her self-titled
surprise album, "Beyoncé,"
had sneaky clues
before their release, too,
like Beyoncé posting pictures
of herself with lemons.
And on Saturday, fans realized
that if you search
Saturday's date, June 11th,
on Beyoncé website,
placeholder art
for a mysterious Beyoncé album
that's just called "B7" came up.
"B7." Beyoncé's seventh album.
Get it?
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-But she didn't release an album
this weekend.
-Are you even listening?
'Cause then Tidal,
the streaming service that Jay-Z
is on the board of,
tweeted, "What is a B7?"
Then just "B8."
Jay-Z is Beyoncé's husband.
So, if and when Beyoncé
puts out a new album,
it could be "B7" and "B8."
That's a double album.
Isn't that crazy?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, it's crazy all right.
Crazy in love!
[ Roots play "Crazy in Love" ]
♪♪
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
Moving on.
I heard that some companies
are allowing workers
to wear shorts --
[ Laughter ]
-Wait!
[ Roots play "Crazy in Love" ]
[ Laughter ]
You're not gonna crawl
on all fours?
-When it comes on, I've got to
get in my -- my moves, man.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, moving on.
I heard that, uh...
[ Laughter ]
...some companies are allowing
workers to wear shorts
in an effort to get them back
in the office this summer.
Yeah. You know a CEO
is desperate when they're like,
"Fine.
You don't have to wear pants."
[ Laughter ]
It's gonna be weird
after meetings to hear 20 pairs
of sweaty thighs
peel off the seats.
Shwwee!
[ Audience groans ]
Also, you guys hear,
but apparently
a pest-control company
is offering $2,000
to families who are willing
to let them release
100 cockroaches
into their homes.
[ Audience groans ]
Yep, 2,000 bucks
for 100 cockroaches.
Right now, the owner of
the Red lobster in Times Square
is like, "I'm gonna be
a billionaire!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, you ever see a photo
in the news
and think that headlines
should be different?
Well, we're gonna take care
of that right now.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was,
"Dr. Fauci says U.S.
is out of pandemic phase."
Yep.
The headline can definitely
be improved because if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been,
"Dad does mic drop
after destroying eulogy."
[ Laughter ]
He's like...
[ Applause ]
-Come on!
-Up next, this headline says,
"Queen Elizabeth beams
at Royal Windsor Horse Show."
The headline could've been,
"Wedding guest gets really into
'Little bit softer now'
portion of 'Shout.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh, oh, way-oh ♪
-This next headline was,
"Biden's job approval numbers
continue to slide."
Headline could've been,
"Father of the bride
clearly taking a leak
in the shrubs."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Ooh!"
-"Oh!"
Next headline was, "BTS holds
White House press briefing."
Headline could've been,
"New FDA commissioners
announce plans to make butter
35% smoother by 2024."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The next headline was,
"Harris announces plan
to cancel
federal student loans."
Headline could've been,
"Mom accidentally walks in
on son's
'personal computer time.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Mom!
It's my personal --
it's my personal computer time."
-Throuple.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Next headline was,
"Prime Minister Trudeau
attends ceremony."
Headline could've been,
"Dad gets just a little high
for PTA meeting."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, this headline was,
"Pope Francis
opens doors for women."
Headline could've been,
"Drunk friend gives final,
reassuring look before eating it
on water skis."
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."
We have a great show.